hello reject nation on Greg Alba who are
you I'm Tara Ericsson I'm gonna match
Tara's energy for all the videos we're
gonna shoot he won't be able to keep up
no you won't see here today people cut
to you falling asleep see it I mean
can't keep up nobody can whoa comedy
improv we're back at it there's this
trailer out from a channel onus on the
chance the studio lose your words a beer
on pictures it's called after it's -
sent to me I was surprised by a movie I
haven't heard of that has 11 million
views trailer that's a lot of views I
was like this has to be based on a book
or some [ __ ] right it's the only logical
explanation or one of these people is a
famous social media star done zero
research on it let's see how it holds on
its own before we do that followed both
Tara and I on the Stardust app okay over
there we do 30 second reaction reviews
or any film TV show or trailer sometimes
micro sketches follow me first because
I'm the one saying it and then follow
tear a second and she posts often to do
is you're gonna follow me first because
that was a jerk move right no words jerk
move right no ladies first gentlemen
there's a little thing called chivalry
between the two of us I'm Way more of a
lady than you can ever be I'm done with
you
oh this is my kind of movies ha he's too
hot it's been like 40 years since you've
been to college so you can't relate yeah
I don't understand this looks like
Twilight
everybody knows splashing water we'll
get somebody to love you now with all
this intimacy
oh yeah where's the conflict I have
nipple chills and I don't know why who
is this [ __ ]
[Music]
why are you dreaming about you not
killing me I mean what is what is going
on in that movie oh I think he's a
stalker it was a really good hot stuff
he's like a high he's like the kind of
guy you want to get stock yeah exactly
stop me for a bit until he murders
people they were all in including with
him her friends with him they're like
hot guy we're on board then they they
fall in love and then all the friends
are like yeah work down with you hot guy
let's murder some people and that's the
old the roses on the table he'd murdered
and so you think this has to do with
actual murder
lots of murdering so much not the event
probabilities in the trailer but there's
so much murder so much murder
that's why Zack what are you dreaming
about because he probably gave me some
weird pill to forget the murders on IMDB
it says a young woman falls for a guy
with a dark secret murder got that and
the to embark on a rocky relationship
yeah based on the novel by add it feels
like that doesn't it doesn't it feel
like you're Fifty Shades Twilight young
adult action oh man relationship he's
probably rock burnt I think this movie
is made for our demographic we're the
ones that this made for us trying to
appeal to right now obviously I'm 19 and
I do shop young adults oh yeah I know is
it totally you reek of 19
uh-huh it's disgusting you smell like 19
[Laughter]
this is the kind of movie I could sit
back with some popcorn maybe get a hot
dog at the theater enjoy my time laugh
when no one else is laughing because I'm
with an audience that is taking this way
too seriously and overall find myself
enjoying a movie that's so bad it's
pretty good it looks kind of hot I guess
it looks appropriate I feel like I would
overall enjoy weirdly I feel like I
would enjoy this movie it looks as
generic as possible how this has 11
million because I don't know
you heard of this book no I haven't
haven't read it gonna go see it gonna
pop up mid mid mid theater when it gets
to the middle sexy parts I'm gonna go
hey any single guys in here got it dark
secret want to come sit over here right
and then one of them at least one you
gotta have one single puppy right he's
like a dark secret
cuz he's all hot and bothered cuz they
do happy boom-boom and then we make out
in the backseat I'll be sure to catch
the background I order I'll order ten
tickets that way the whole roads to
myself oh yeah that's sex that's a room
to just talk and chat make fun of the
movie and then also just share our deep
dark secret it's nothing sexual though I
just want a guy to come and share all
his secrets I gotta come I get it now so
college girl goes through a school meets
dark mysterious guy everyone encourages
her to go hook up with dark mysterious
guy when she starts hooking up with him
everyone starts saying you shouldn't be
hooking up with dark mysterious guy and
they're both too beautiful white people
he has a British accent that makes him
even more sexy I feel like there has to
be something more of a unique hook here
though there has to be Tara I feel like
maybe secretly he comes from a weird
family well cuz you said earlier that a
British was like sexier and so now I'm
trying this out to see if like you guys
like it you know what I mean you ought
to go after after officer was why's it
called after exactly cuz after he turned
16 he became an eligible bachelor and
his parents were like go take a girl and
then murder all her primers for movies
like this that have such a obviously
strong fan base with its book base up
this view can I know that we have said
so many people by not taking this
seriously whatsoever maybe they're dead
maybe he wanted the guys actually dead
and he's in the afterlife oh wait a
minute it's actually a great
that's a cool look I hope the movie does
that right because this trailer does all
the typical generic stuff that supposed
to make it seem intense it was like
every fifty shades trailer some guy gets
punched you see some dead flowers so
much warning you at the end
I feel like this movie has no real
conflict in here this is like a sex
novel
it's like one of those like Fifty Shades
novels it sort of feels that way doesn't
it it's just a sexy novel these comments
are loving this third of what is
everybody's hot yes wait that's my call
for hot in case I can't use the word hot
people are like we don't like that word
then I go fine that's my call it's good
oh yeah I was pleasant oh yeah oh yeah
this is half my mate is my dance call
too I would do it for this guy right if
I saw him it was dead dude it's better
than if you're a ghost
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you guys have no idea okay to all the
twelve-year-old girls who happen to
stumble upon this reaction I am sorry
for not being as invested in this as you
probably hoped who would be but it looks
generically fun everyone's hot it feels
borderline steamy I feel like that for
your demographic you will be satisfied
yes and we will be here going this was
fun this was fun
this was fun also glad you're reading so
if whatever gets you reading so glad you
guys are reading novels you know yeah
real good always this is like Ernest
Hemingway [ __ ] right here right blowing
your mind kind of stuff someone's
blowing yeah subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification
tear it sit on her shadow follow us both
in the Stardust app Terra make you make
your Indian cry dark secret dark secret
boy it's just like the old days